we're going to move on for now to
Eastern Ohio where people from the town
of East Palestine
had the opportunity to confront the CEO
of Norfolk Southern over the company's
handling of the trained derailment in
that town former president Donald Trump
also spent time in the area yesterday
and took the opportunity to criticize
President Biden who has been overseas of
course criticizing Biden for not
visiting the community Roxanna saberi
has been there for days now she's a
nearby Youngstown Ohio Roxanna good
morning
Good morning Tony residents around here
say they're still not getting the full
story from officials and Norfolk
Southern most of all they're afraid the
place they've called home might never be
the same again
my sister was right next to the tracks
with her fiancee
she could have been killed this angry
East Palestine citizens got the chance
to speak publicly to Norfolk Southern
CEO Alan Shaw for the first time
yesterday since the toxic train
derailment and they made their feelings
clear did you shorten my life now I want
to retire and enjoy it how are we going
to enjoy it
you you burned me
we were going to sell our house our
value went
we're gonna get the cleanup right we're
going to reimburse the Citizens We're
going to invest in the long-term health
of this community despite repeated EPA
assurances that the city's water wells
are unaffected and the air is safe
residents are still wary of heavily
polluted soil and Creeks like this one
CBS News filmed just yesterday
right
earlier in the day former president
Trump toured the site to the February
3rd derailment I like that one but this
was even nice situated in deep red
Columbiana County which Trump took with
more than 70 percent of the vote in 2020
East Palestine greeted him warmly
her president wasted no time blasting
the current president for not coming to
East Palestine sooner I sincerely hope
that when your representatives and all
of the politicians get here including
Biden they get back from touring Ukraine
that he's got some money left over the
Trump has received criticism from
democrats for rolling back regulations
in the rail industry during his
presidency many here welcomed the visit
what do you think about President Trump
coming to the area it was exciting to
hear
Bridget piles lives in Negley a small
town around four miles from East
Palestine I'm afraid of the chemicals
coming here and the after effects and
you know you don't know you're not going
to know until you know who knows months
years
the NTSB is expected to release its
preliminary report on the disaster later
this morning and transportation
secretary Pete budage will make an
appearance in town today after receiving
heavy backlash for not visiting sooner
Roxanna thank you I'll take it